this is kinetic
fire 1998 1998 1998 Chris Kelly Tori
Johnson
threo Advanced threo Workshop
recap
uh first thing okay we went over the
patterns and Wall play with the single
side Superman where the balance happens
on one side so it's like you're doing
normal Superman pacing forward you turn
your left hand
and lift up so the balance is just
happening in front of
you and then moving with a tri ketra on
the other side your body and that can
also be done instead of balance in front
of you it can be done with the balance
in back as well as a triet in
back instead of a dumb Le Superman you
can do Inky Le Superman and all those
same
combos of the front
and back
yeah went over was like swap
stuff um going back and
forth and then do the
legs and uh behind the
back and then we talked about the crazy
double toss
thing basically that one
with you get the idea um and then double
tossing find your back under your
leg and and the leg
one do it again do it again do it do it
again sure sure
thing um and then that butterfly tossing
stuff into
same and and the opal illusion one so
here first
one tosing back and
forth
same oh and I'll throw this one
in we that one
again
more sck hand
switch so yeah that was it I don't know
uh try like the stuff that I was just
doing try C versus the the one bounce
but the bounce doesn't have to happen on
the outside of your non-native side if
you step out with the non-native leg you
can bounce on the inside of your native
leg and you switch between the two you
get this cool little walking
motion um or if you step with your
non-native leg behind native leg you
have the bounce happen like on the
outside kind of forward or front part of
the non-native leg kind of almost in the
same spot as when it normally
does
um also do an extension with the one
side
belance can also be done inside or
cross uh we talked about two pedal in
spins vers four pedal an spin
together
so that's two beats in front and the one
beat in back two beats in front one in
back and bounce to come over the single
point
hand and right as that bounce happens on
the nonnative side you start doing the
an with it following
through uh that pattern instead of your
hands Crossing could also be done more
in like a wheel plane so on either side
of your body more yeah more
like less classing
points um this
thing it's pretty simple just a
butterfly versus static toy if you get
down
caps move the down C with the dangle of
the single boy do the co
illusion uh we worked on this butterfly
Point ISO thing which is UPC caps and
when it comes down on your non-native
side you get a point ISO by putting a
little bit of slaping your pinky and
lifting up a little bit crossing
over this going to be done three
Play We Done split as
well four four probably do
five
more the negative space negative space
so if you create your negative space
with a single point hand on uh non
native
side have your Superman your face
forward super magnitud your left
90° and as the weaving po my thumb po
that PO is in front of me it's going to
come into the negative space and on the
next beat up you're going to toss and
move out of the negative
space create NE space comes up next beat
toss come
out
netive space
up
out um you can also do flip of the
negative space Point instead of just
lifting out flick back and catch the one
that you flip with the one hand
point you do anything
else probably probably did other things
but uh I think it's
almost that's good I didn't know where
pretty much all at it's all good Chris
Kelly Tory Johnson kinetic fire fire
1998 represent Advan threo
shop